now a second cargo ship has sailed from
the port of Odessa in Ukraine despite
the threat of Russian attack the Primus
is sailing a long a new humanitarian
Corridor in the Black Sea now it was
opened after Russia withdrew from the
Black Sea grain deal last month which
guaranteed safe passage to vessels
carrying Ukrainian exports Ukrainian
government has warned of the threat from
Russian warship attacks and mine
explosions
Robert bride is standing by for us in
Keith monitoring events for us and
obviously there have been some attacks
in the northeast of the country Rob but
the International Community really
continuing to hold its breath as another
grain shipment leaves a Ukrainian port
that's right this is seen as a quite uh
consequential according to ship tracking
apps uh this vessel it's on its way to
Vanda on the Bulgarian coaster and it's
still on its way it departed from uh the
port city of Odessa on Saturday it's
only the second ship to depart from that
Port since the lifting uh the Russia
ended this uh grain deal they're
guaranteeing the safe passage of grain
ships across the Black Sea now this
Corridor has been set up without any
agreement from the Russians there is
still the threat of sea mines of
potential attack also the shippers have
to contend with very high insurance
rates but this has been set up by
Ukraine as a way of getting ships that
have been stuck in Ukrainian Port since
the start of the war to finally get them
uh going again but potentially in the
future of trying to re-establish grain
exports from the Ukrainian coast and in
we've seen in recent weeks and months
Ukraine looking for alternative routes
of land borders and also the seaports or
the River ports on that feed into the
Danube River as a way of getting a grain
exports and food export out of Ukraine
but while those have been effective it's
still if we're going to see a return to
the kind of food exports that we had
pre-war then there is this General
acceptance that they have to somehow try
to start the mass export of food from
these large ports on the Ukrainian Black
Sea Coast if we certainly pivot to sort
of the Ukrainian counter offensive that
we're hearing about what more can you
tell us about that
yeah there is uh still the focus that
tends to be on the uh Southern front
especially around the village of
robertine this is where the ukrainians
have in the past couple of weeks uh been
making uh some a progress against these
uh formidable Russian uh defenses
there's been a lot of frustration I
think from Western pundits military
experts about the lack of progress with
with this much vaunted much longer
weighted counter offensive that's been
going on for a couple of months now and
there is some pushback almost resentment
here in Ukraine that they were unfair
expectations about the pace of this uh
of this counter-offensive given the fact
that the Russians have had months to dig
in and create this defense in depth
there was also the breaching of the
kakovka dam which flooded much of the
front line where this counter-offensive
would come but also as ukrainians here
will tell you while they've had Western
training and NATO equipment what they
still lack is superiority the you know
the idea of f-16s flying over the the
Skies of Ukraine is still months away
and as they make the point that NATO
forces would never dream of trying to
have a ground counter-offensive on this
scale without air superiority but
progress is uh being made finally it
seems towards this a strategically
important town of tokmak beyond that
very far beyond that is the coast of the
Sea of azov and there is a feeling from
bloggers here and also military
commanders on the Ukrainian side that
are some of the worst of the defenses
have been overcome in that area while
there's still a lot of fighting to do
that we may see an increase in the pace
of the Ukraine in advance Robert brought
for us there in Kiev thank you